hello there so gta 5 re-released on its
third console generation and like a lot
of people i've been replaying the
campaign all over again this time though
i deliberately failed every single
mission to see what happened and yes
most of the time it's the same old
failed text on screen yet sometimes to
my surprise there are some ultra rare
cutscenes to witness i'll put them in
order of gruesomeness so stick around
till the end if you want to see what
happens in this scene or this scene or
yeah you get the idea i'd like to make
more gta content so please if you like
this click like it's really appreciated
oh and spoilers are definitely coming
for this nine-year-old game first to the
jewelry heist mission in which michael
and franklin attempt to rob a store full
of rocks in broad daylight there is
plenty of time to make a getaway but
have you ever wondered what happens if
you don't make it out the door in time
see for yourself
that was out you know
the very first time franklin and michael
meet involves breaking into michael's
home to repo a car in this mission we
are told to avoid michael's wife
daughter and son but what happens if we
don't
should franklin be spotted by tracy
you'll see this fail screen
if we are spotted by jimmy he'll react
like this
and down in the kitchen is amanda and
the tennis coach who will give you this
unforgettable reaction
[Music]
after we take the vehicle michael pops
up to control the situation and orders
us to go back to the car lot should we
drive around long enough or drive
completely in the wrong direction you'll
be treated to this cutscene
this don't look like the way to no
credit alec to me
man with traffic and all this way is
fast don't move kid
[Music]
in the mission minor turbulence we fly a
plane into a bigger plane and then steal
that plane along the way we are shot
down and usually we jump clear and
parachute to safety well it turns out we
can indeed stay in the plane and watch
it crash down my favorite part of this
is how bored trevor looks while waiting
for this to happen
during the father and son mission
michael and franklin are getting to know
each other and suddenly michael's boat
is stolen with jimmy on board we take to
the highway to rescue him and retrieve
that boat there are a couple of extra
fail scenes to witness here first if we
take out the henchmen but never catch up
to save jimmy by the end of the bridge
this will happen
[Music]
quite understated to say he's just lost
his son whereas if we are able to save
jimmy but don't help franklin back down
another cut scene is triggered
[Applause]
dad don't be all butthurt at least you
got me out of there you listen to me you
little [ __ ] that kid just jumped off the
hood of a moving car to save your ass
and now he's gone and so is my boat my
guy really like that boat
next we move on to the three endings of
the game i'm betting you chose option c
death wish to keep all three characters
alive so in that case let's look at the
other options the second option is to
take out michael which gives us three
ways to finish the game albeit only with
small minor changes after franklin
corners michael on a high ledge the two
are left struggling to hold on to each
other our options are simple drop
michael or save him dropping him is
exactly what you'd expect franklin opens
his grip and the big man goes splat hey
you told me when the time came
i know i'm sorry
but what if we tried to save michael
instead i know i'm sorry yeah hypocrite
i should have clipped you when you broke
into my house man i'm sorry
it's like you said i understand
michael headbutts franklin and still go
splat the only difference to the ending
cut scene is a broken nose for franklin
so i loaded up again and this time i did
absolutely nothing i just waited to see
what happened and it's completely
underwhelming after a minute or two
their grips will become weakened and
michael still goes splat
if we choose to take out trevor a chase
scene takes us to this moment trevor is
t-boned into a tank of fuel and covered
from head to toe we are then told to
shoot him which franklin does of course
the second version of this is if we
hauled off shooting if we refuse to
shoot trevor this will happen instead
michael steps up and does the dirty work
that was his best friend
out of interest i also tried to shoot
michael here it's not possible during
the movie premiere mission for meltdown
we are given two minutes to go back home
to save our wife and daughter from a
private army so i sat around to see what
happened
just a boring fail screen i then tried
this again just waiting outside the
house again another fail screen but if
we go inside and don't react we'll see
this happen
i am seriously gonna shoot you
[Music]
both amanda and tracy are taken out if
we do save them though we are treated to
a scene of jimmy teabagging his father
but a touching moment one of the most
traumatizing missions in gta is by the
book as michael watches a safe house
while trevor terrorizes a man for
information my first thought here to get
an extra cutscene is to not do anything
at all and i can confirm that trevor
will just pace up and down and will
never stop until the player makes a
decision which means we have to indulge
in those
trees may i recommend the nutcracker if
we don't keep an eye on the heartbeat of
mr k he will flatline giving us the
option to give him a shot to bring him
back to life but if we don't do that and
just stand there and watch we get this
cut scene instead
that's what happens when you put the
body through the ringer
[Music]
now hold on hold on
hold on
[Music]
hey i just spent past few hours
torturing a seemingly innocent guy to
death and i don't even know why i did it
so does that make me come on
you're going down punk at the exact
moment i get bored with you your little
racket
will end yeah yeah you love those
tough guy lines don't you huh
in the mission dead man walking michael
is thwacked over the head and sent to a
mog looking like a cadaver the coroners
open his body and are surprised to see
him wake up and the mission continues
but there are actually two more versions
of this scene the first happens if
michael stays completely still have a
listen to this
what we got
john doe white male overweight in his
late 40s possible corner let's take a
peek
the fat deposits on his hips and abdomen
suggest a fondness for bleeder burgers
we're probably about to find one in his
gut still on his wrapper right next to
the bottle of scotch and pack of
redwoods see the broken capillaries
around the nose
alcoholic i wouldn't take any bets on
the state of the liver we still think
40s takes a toll he's an advert for
clean living note the discoloration of
the teeth
and the fingers smoker pack a day i'd
say probably cigars too i was going like
there was no tomorrow he's got that
right
some people think they're immortal so
you get chest pains pumping away at your
mistress lucky girl having this thing on
top of her huh she was probably relieved
when he bought it awkward conversation
with the spouse
might have got some hush money it's a
win-win
only losers are the chumps who got to
cut him open the rule cause of death
get ready with the bone saw
and the rib spreader
you might want to hold your nose
so he was killed whilst playing dead oh
the irony it's also possible to move a
little during the autopsy and one of the
coroners will notice
what the hell was that don't worry it's
just gas no no
it's reanimating you want to cut it in
the corner's office you're going to have
to lose the nerves i've been around
cadavers this isn't right well fresh is
different the ones you've seen have been
on the shelf for a week you can still
smell this guy's breakfast if you say so
ah the things i've seen in this place
grown man you could fit into a sandwich
bag bodies that are more maggots than
flesh
this gas bag here is a blessing but
unless we get off of our back the same
ending will happen i mean you can shake
your head around like there's no
tomorrow and once they've noticed once
they'll just crack on literally
now to the fresh meat mission michael is
taken by the triads and is strung up to
a um food processor and is about to
become minced meat michael we are
supposed to rescue him with franklin but
where's the fun in that instead i
decided to wait and watch and
approximately six minutes later
[Music]
out of interest i wondered what would
happen to franklin if he accidentally
went into that machine and oh well it's
exactly it's exactly what you'd expect
so that's it 14 secret cutscenes you may
have missed if you played the game how
it was intended i'm adam you're awesome
i'll see you next time